hello and welcome to the 21st PHP
tutorial more we left off we were
writing an appending files and we had
this mission form I mean it was pretty
epic so but now what we want to do is
kind of change gears and talk real quick
about one more type of security and
that's going to be hashing so we'll
continue including this hetero PHP but
let me delete this let me leave a form
and let's just start nice and clean
now what hashing is is kind of like a
way to obfuscate your text data and it's
kind of it's a one-way encryption but
it's definitely it's not it's not like
legally backed encryption okay so like
in my Python tutorials I showed how to
do a 128-bit AES encryption which is
like an official type of encryption so
if you're accepting like user credit
card information or something like that
in your and you lose that data you can
be held liable for the lost data unless
of course you encrypted it with 128-bit
encryption right so hashing is not
necessarily the most secure way to do it
but it is a pretty popular way to at
least take steps towards securing data
and then later on I'll show you even
further
you can even better secure that data so
so let us let's just say we have a user
information and we'll specify variable
as PW and that's going to be their
password and we'll just say their
password is password so and then to use
hashing it's just md5 so we'll just call
this hashed equals md5 and then within
here we want to apply this to password
now what we'll do is we'll just let's
echo out password or I'm sorry hashed
hashed version of that password so let's
save that we'll re-upload and run it
continue and here is the hashed version
of a misspelled password now what if we
do this again like let's do you know if
you're familiar with encryption almost
every time you generate it every time
you generate it there's randomization
and so it's a different value every time
so let's say PW 2 hashed giving 2 and
now we want to echo hashed to save that
and we'll run that it's on the same one
let me go ahead and kind of quick break
here
okay so now you can see it's the exact
same value and so the point of hashing
is usually what people hash our
passwords so what you'll have is a
system that when a user specifies the
password it hashes it immediately and
saves their password not it never saves
the actual lettering password instead it
saves the hash of password and then what
it happens when they go to login is they
type in password it runs it through it
like converts it to the md5 hashing and
then it compares that this to that and
it sees okay that was a match and it
continues on so then what happens if you
just to show you let's change a password
and dude let's actually spell password
right the first time so we'll save that
and reload it refresh and you can see
it's like almost like completely
different but if it is identical it's
the same so this presents a little bit
of a security risk in the way that that
means there is a finite number of
combinations and everyone who uses md5
no matter what the website is if the
users password is password it's going to
look just like this so what happens is
the reason people do this is in case
someone gets database access and like
downloads the database instead of the
actual password they get this numerical
data which is pretty much worthless they
can't log in with it but if they have a
really large database that has all kinds
of combinations in it converted to hash
values they could theoretically build up
a database so to give you an idea of
this it would take a while right because
I like to say you know you've got 26
types of characters that you could have
and let's say you've got you know a
maximum of 3 you know just as an example
password it'll be 26 by 26 by 26 and so
but it's a big number it's a big issue
number but it represents a finite number
if you have 20 characters that you allow
and you allow every single letter in the
alphabet uppercase lowercase and numbers
and symbols it represents a massive
number it really does buy it it's a
finite number and it's not massive
enough for a bunch of computers to never
crack in fact it would you know it might
take a couple years or something like
that but I'll tell you this the year is
2013 md5 hashing has been around for
quite some time it's been done there
there are already websites out there
that will convert hash to code because
it's just you know it takes a while to
build the database but once you have it
every time password is going to equal
this so then all it takes is like okay
well we got this hash value we send it
through the the database of hashes it
finds it in like a split second you know
so it's not the best thing that you can
do but it is a proper step so what's the
next step that you can do to better
secure that and that's going to be
what's called salting and if you want to
know what salting is I suggest you
consult the next video as always thanks
for watching and until next time